oui j'ai été très très amoureuse d'une
personne autour de la table il ya
quelques années je travaille en télé je
le regardais présenter tellement
gentille et j'étais folle amoureuse
non mais c'est pas une blague de
matthieu delormeau et oui avant que
j'apprenne que bon mais non mais non
[Applaudissements]
j'étais oui j'ai osé médian en faites
quoi quoi s'est amusé magnifique où vous
étiez amoureuse de monsieur de
nombreuses derrière ma télé 2 mathieu de
leurs moyens à l'époque quand on m'a
appelé pour être chroniqueuse sur le
mile et pour venir en invité j'étais
tout excité parce que j'avais enfin
rencontré mathieu de leur moral est bas
après qu'elle eut quand elle est arrivée
la notion de droit et voilà qu'une autre
méthode
j'ai essayé de le draguer puis je voyais
qu'il avait pas trop d'heures
en fait vous c'est tout le contraire de
moi en fait et donc ouais
et ben voilà et du coup je n'ai jamais
dit je pense qu'il est même choqué parce
qu'il le savait pas mais en très mes
parents le savent parce qu'après je
regardais tellement vrai je disais
[ __ ] mais c'est vraiment c'était pour
moi mais l'homme idéal
ah ouais c'était trop mon style de l'est
maintenant c'est votre homme idéal ah
bon non mes soirées non mais bah oui oui
a balayé je veux bien qu'on est beau il
est il est intelligent il est bien il
est drôle mais je n'étais pas amoureuse
de benjamin castaldi
oui si c'est ce que vous nous aviez dit
à la fois les vidéos qui amoureux de
benjamin castaldi grommelle un peu
volage pas pourquoi ça pourrait être mon
père dont
je veux leur meilleur visage ça pourrait
pas de votre père wynn holmes est vrai
que votre grand père et mère très bonne
confession à la manche mal j'ai rien
senti comme à draguer face avant du
compte
moi je me suis bien embêté hermétique en
même temps c'est mal foutu la vie elle
est amoureuse de moi je me veux vous
dire et personne ne veut céder mais
bizarrement ça changera pas